joey diaz and i started together you
know in seattle me and joe and brody
and uh joe's lived in my house a bunch
and we go back a long time and i
remember talking with him openly about
telling him there's no way you reach 50
years old dude there's no way
you know i think he was at one let me
tell you something [ __ ]
but at his heaviest he was over 400
pounds bill
oh yeah oh yeah
he was a big [ __ ] dude he was do you
know
so just like lenny he has no middle
ground he went from not smoking
cigarettes
ever a day in his life to smoking a pack
and a half a day the first day he smoked
cigarettes he smoked a pack
and a half oh wow so that's
you know that that's who he is but i
remember
that's but that's also why his comedy is
so great
because if he's going to do a subject
you know he's smoking the whole pack you
know what i mean he's not going to sit
there and just be like well this is kind
of interesting
no he's not leaving anything on the
table at all yeah do you know i remember
when we started with him and i don't
know if you know anybody that you
started with that did this
brody and him were the same in that
when they were doing their actual jokes
they were bombing
and they didn't kill until they got so
mad that they were bombing
that they just started to become
themselves
and as soon as they started like as soon
as brody was brody was bombing one night
and he bombed in a unique way that like
nobody bombed like him
and he went into this thing about he was
like
you know you guys are laughing but he
said i'm a little anxious tonight
he was like do you know how hard it is
for a single man
to shave his own back he said i have
trouble spots and he turned around and
he lifted up his shirt
and he had like patches of hair on his
back where you could see
he couldn't reach with his head
and i was like oh this dude's [ __ ]
crazy
but when he did [ __ ] like that it blew
it up
but when he wrote jokes he was like a
completely both of them
were completely their jokes made them
seem like completely different people
than who they actually were
when joey went off listen to your
[ __ ] that's some funny [ __ ]
people went crazy but like
yeah brody's one of those guys you know
where
i don't know how many thousands of times
i saw him do stand up but
i can't remember anything other than
laughing my ass off and looking at
another comedian
going like just being like can you
believe this [ __ ] like
like he really was just doing
his own uh
his own thing i think the thing about
that this it's this weird thing where
they're not traditional comedians right
but they're [ __ ] hilarious so they
almost have to go up and go
all right here's stand-up comedy yeah
and then they try that i remember when
he passed and there was so many
that's so many but i got no dude i watch
this guy's clip this guy isn't funny
it's like dude because
this isn't it this this isn't what he
did like they never really captured what
he did
uh although uh the zach galifianakis
show they did on comedy central was the
closest thing
yeah like those are guys you just you
it's like dude you can't just see this
guy once
you can't watch him on tv this is a guy
you have to go
you have to go to the club yeah
and you have to get to where his brain
is at and then once
once that you guys are on the same
frequency it's like you push through the
matrix and this guy's going to make you
laugh like a [ __ ] comedian
a hundred percent you have to you had to
see brody live
there was no doubt about it 100 had to
see him live
and i so for me with brody what was you
know how you said he's not a traditional
comic
because he actually had you laughing at
things that if you
looked at if say he wrote his punch
lines down on a piece of paper
you might not be able to pick out the
punchline like the fact that he got a
laugh
off of his gpa right he would tell you
what classes he took at arizona state
and what his gp what his gpa was and he
had people laughing
that to me was like he was he was
so different which is why i think
it was inverted yes with everybody else
there was there act the crowd laughs you
walk over to get a drink of water
then you're back in your raft his
getting a drink of water was his jokes
he did it opposite exactly
she had watched a ton of comedy i don't
think it made sense what
how his brain was it was like he was
literally up as down
black is white right his left yeah the
whole thing was on its head
and i i think that that's why uh
i know he's just he was just so [ __ ]
bill i remember i thought to this day i
still can't even explain why what he was
doing was funny what he was saying
i always tell the story the one thing i
really vividly remember was one night he
went up there
and described his dream two-bedroom
apartment
and all he was saying was details
yeah but that's funny coming out of this
boat that's funny
stepping down
apple cider vinegar like why does that
matter
girl yeah you're doing all stuff like
that uh
bill you know one time on the table
might be real
might not be negative energy arms
crossed negative energy arms crossed
in seattle yet the old comedy
underground did you ever play the old
comedy underground
i played that one that that guy he used
to give you a shoebox full of cash at
the [ __ ] end of it that
guy terry yeah yeah that was giggles
that was gay that guy was a character in
the yeah he
literally gave you a door deal so it's
like all fives and ones and twenties and
tens all
jammed together it's just like dude what
the [ __ ] is this
i'm not going to the airport looking
like some drug dealer yeah and he used
to say count it up i think it's all
there i'm like
what i don't but one time in seattle
pioneer square is where comedy
underground was next to the comedy
underground
was just a place where there was a lot
of homeless people and there was a dude
who was dressed like a clown um
and like basically it looked like
15 years ago he had performed at a party
as a clown
and just never took the costume off and
lived
outside from that time do you know what
i mean like the flower just happened
yeah yeah something about clown
makeup that you can never quite wipe off
well no it was smearing
the joker they go crazy there's
something about that [ __ ]
it's it was smeared his he would push
his flower and it just dribbled
it was sad right but brody brings him on
stage one night at the comedy
underground the open mic
um because he was always a very
experimental dude and for me one of the
things that that is one of the things
that i always admired about him
especially early on
to be such a young comic and be so
experimental
i didn't have that kind of confidence do
you know what i mean to really go up and
try something that you
pretty much knew was going to eat dicks
was not something i
had the capability to do but he always
did and he brought this
clown on stage and i forget what his
name is he's like george whatever
and he goes everybody this george you
know i'm sure you've seen him down here
in pioneer square but george
you know i've talked to him the last
couple weeks and he's always want to be
a comic so i'm going to give him my time
for the open mic and go ahead george and
so
there's you know about 30 or 40 people
down there and
george tells a couple of jokes and uh
they're not funny believe it or not and
um
but you know the crowd thinks this is
part of the gig they don't think it's
actually some homeless dude
off the street and george you can see
him
he's not holding it together quite as
well he's
no laughter is really starting to get to
him so brody can sense that
and he walks up and he puts his arm
around them and he goes come on
everybody
this is george's dream let's give george
a little energy and george looks at
brody he goes
touch me again and i'll murder every
[ __ ] person in this room and i was
like oh
oh boy
you might have brought her in the wrong
direction and how did brody handle it
he was like george everybody come on one
more time for george and he grabbed the
mic and they gave him the light
it was really you know he was um
you could put him in any situation
[Music]
[Music]
you